the opening scene features a government
officer named Catherine Moore who
arrives at a secret research lab there
she is received by a scientist Richard
faler who then asks his assistant Reese
to park Catherine's car don't scuff the
Leather Reese you little hoe Richard
leads her inside the research facility
to demonstrate his groundbreaking
invention he then commands his
co-workers to initiate an experimental
procedure they use Catherine's car for
the experiment reassuring her of its
safety can't you use yours they start to
increase the electrical current and much
to Catherine's astonishment her car
eventually Fades from view afterward
they reduce the electrical power
bringing the vehicle back to its visible
State Richard happily proclaims that he
has succeeded in achieving invisibility
through the experiment however his
happiness is shortlived as the Machinery
in the control room malfunctions they
hear a voice over the radio and the
electrical current suddenly escalates
causing the car to vanish the scene then
cuts to 12 mies west of Philadelphia
where a pilot is preparing for takeoff
moments before the aircraft leaves the
runway an electromagnetic portal appears
out of nowhere and a massive warship
emerges from it as a result the aircraft
collides with the warship resulting in a
huge explosion oh couldn't have been
avoided in the next scene we are
introduced to a woman named Molly
Gardner who works at a coffee shop she
is currently helping her colleague Lena
in an illegal task hacking official
websites to make fake bill payments
shortly after a sheriff named Carl Reed
walks into the shop and talks to Molly
through the conversation we learned that
they like each other but Molly for some
reason is turning him down for marriage
amid their flirty conversation Carl
receives news about the aircraft
explosion prompting him to rush off the
scene upon arrival Carl is taken aback
by the sight of a massive ship called
the USS Eldridge crashing on the runway
he immediately recognizes this ship as
the one that had mysteriously vanished
during the time of the second world war
in a quick action he alerts the Navy
force and also summons additional backup
to conduct an investigation back at the
research facility Richard and his team
discover that the voice they previously
heard came from the USS eldrid when he
seeks further information from Catherine
she discloses that the ship had vanished
during its original experiment in 1943
and it was presumed destroyed when it
never reappeared meanwhile a man named
Bill Gardner regains Consciousness
inside the warship with no recollection
of what happened he tries to stand up
only to discover that his shoes are
stuck to the floor he somehow manages to
take off off his shoes and proceeds to
find the rest of his fellow crew members
however he's startled to find their
lifeless bodies in a statue like form he
tries to use the radio signals to
connect with the control room but to no
avail as he wanders around he comes
across a mysterious portal he nervously
reaches out to touch it only to be
sucked in and transported outside the
ship outside Carl calls Molly and
conveys information about the USS
Eldridge prompting her to rush to the
location the sheriff cautiously
approaches the ship and comes comes into
contact with the electromagnetic field
surrounding it as a consequence he is
unexpectedly teleported inside the ship
Molly arrives at the scene and is
informed by a worker that Carl has been
sucked in before she can take any action
the electrical current surges generating
a substantial electromagnetic field that
causes the entire ship to vanish yet
again on the other hand Bill wanders
aimlessly in the city street with a
confused expression on his face moreover
he is shocked to see today's date as he
just time traveled from 1943 following
this he makes his way to the coffee shop
where Molly Works Bill talks to Lena
inquiring about how he can contact the
Navy Lena suggests using a website but
Bill is completely unaware of modern
computer systems he then asks Lena about
a woman named Mary Gardner who happens
to be Molly's grandmother Lena provides
information about Molly but Bill remains
perplexed and departs at the research
facility the workers discover that their
generators are drawing power even if if
they're Switched Off just then the
electric power Rises once again it also
has a simultaneous effect on Bill as he
experiences an electricution meanwhile
in Chicago the USS Eldridge reappears
midair and Falls onto a tall building
inside the ship Carl finds his right
hand embedded in the ship's wall later
that evening Molly returns home and
finds Bill inside she is astounded to
learn that he is her grandfather who
disappeared alongside the USS Aldridge
70 years ago as they start conversing
Molly reveals that her grandmother died
when she was very young and her mother
passed away 3 years ago Bill gets
emotional to hear this but he is
determined to uncover the truth behind
the ship's mysterious disappearance to
assist him Molly hacks the Navy's
website because she's young and she can
hack you know and presents him with the
files related to the first Philadelphia
Experiment project rainbow explaining
how the ship was believed to have been
destroyed in the meantime Richard and
Catherine arrive at another research
facility located in Chicago after
reviewing all the files related to the
original experiment Richard learns that
the experiment was based on time travel
during that experiment the Excess power
of their generator created a massive
energy field that tore a rift in the
SpaceTime Continuum and when Richard's
team activated their phase generator
their field got connected with the
original one resulting in the Eldridge
being pulled through space and time
causing it to reappear in the present
day according to Richard it's been 70
years for them but for the ship it was
an instantaneous Journey back at Molly's
place she informs her grandfather about
her boyfriend Carl who is now stuck
inside the ship their conversation is
abruptly interrupted by the doorbell
Molly answers it and a man named haggan
introduces himself as a government
official he demands for Bill's
whereabouts and resorts to threats when
she remains silent moments later bill
suddenly attacks the guy and knocks him
down before fleeing with Molly the duo
then head to Lena borrow her car and
obtain some cash before driving away
elsewhere Catherine summons an incursion
team and authorizes them to destroy the
ship but right then then Richard
receives a call from reys who reports
that the phase generator is still active
and the field intensity is increasing
rapidly this indicates that the ship is
on the verge of Disappearing again in
addition he warns that its effect will
be huge compared to the previous
disappearances upon hearing this Richard
asks Catherine to issue a retreat order
to the incursion team but she ignores
him meanwhile Bill and Molly reach a pay
phone where they receive a call from an
unknown person the growing field
intensity around the ship affects Bill
rendering him unable to communicate on
the phone as a result Molly grabs the
receiver and the person on the other end
mentions Ivory gate a few moments later
the electrical current surges to a level
where it generates a powerful magnetic
field causing the ship to vanish once
more the next day Bill tells Molly that
they must go to Morton's Salinger the
one who started the time travel
experiment on the USS Eldridge in the
past it turns out that Morton is the
same person they spoke to on the pay
phone earlier Molly claims that he's
dead but Bill remains convinced vinced
that he's alive just like himself after
a while of driving they arrive at a port
where they find Morton who is aged
unlike Bill Morton Express his
astonishment that his experiment
actually succeeded he mentions that the
government shut down all operations when
the ship disappeared despite this he
faked his own death and continued to
work on his experiments secretly he also
explains that the generator bonded the
atoms of Bill's body to Eldridge which
is why he keeps getting affected back at
the research lab Richard predicts the
potential locations where the ship made
May reappear amidst this Catherine
receives a call from Haggen who is
revealed to have been working for her
from the beginning he informs her that
through intercepted Communications he
has discovered that Morton is still
alive and he is currently meeting with
Bill and Molly determined to end
everything once and for all Catherine
instructs him to assassinate all three
of them she also plans to bomb the USS
Eldridge as soon as it reappears hearing
this Richard tries to warn her about its
consequences but she doesn't seem to
care as a result he orders Reese to shut
down on the phase generator and cut off
the field linkage with the ship right
away elsewhere Morton leads Bill and
Molly to his secret research facility on
their way they are ambushed by Haggen
and his henchmen who open fire on them
causing a high stakes car chase through
the woods Morton guides them to a path
where he has set up a booby trap and
manages to blast the enemy car but sadly
he is shot in the process which injures
him severely the duo then pulls over at
a distance and Morton in his final
breath tells them that they now have to
stop all of this without him those final
words were obvious according to the old
man bill and the Eldridge firstly have
to get back to 1943 he also informs them
of the way to his secret research
facility and mentions his colleague
named Khan who will help them through
this left with no other choice Bill and
Molly reluctantly abandoned Morton and
proceed to the research facility shortly
afterward Haggen who survived the
explosion approaches the dying Morton
and demands to know Bill's whereabouts
when he refuses to divulge any
information
Haggin shoots the old man to death
meanwhile at Richard's research lab
Reese and the team are working to break
the field linkage however a power surge
occurs causing the field intensity to
rise up sensing the imminent danger
Reese rushes into the Machinery room to
rescue the remaining team members only
to be drawn into the electromagnetic
field oh God Reese simultaneously
Richard is watching CCTV footage of Bill
experiencing the electrocution this
leads him to realize that bill is the
key to resolving the situation as only
he can shut down the system Richard then
sneaks out of the Chicago research lab
and makes his way towards bill in the
next scene Catherine dispatches a Delta
Force to the Sahara Desert where the
Eldridge is predicted to reappear true
to their assumption the Aldridge
materializes at the predicted time and
Catherine orders the Delta team to blow
it up the force launches multiple
missiles toward the ship but the
presence of an electromagnetic field
acts as a protective barrier rendering
the missiles ineffective soon after the
field intensity Rises once more more and
the ship is transported to a nuclear
plant in England resulting in a massive
explosion sometime later Billy and Molly
arrive at Morton's research laboratory
but they are met with a grim sight all
the team members have been killed
sensing the danger they grab a laptop
and make their way out as they exit the
building they once again come under
attack by Haggen and his armed
Associates Haggen opens fire on Bill but
he is shielded by an electromagnetic
field just like the ship it's at this
moment that he realizes that he can use
this electrical current to repel the
asants in the midst of this commotion
Richard shows up and rescues the two of
them from Hagen he drives them to his
secret lab explaining that he possesses
the generators capable of bringing the
Aldridge there as soon as they reach the
lab they activate the machinery and
initiate the process to generate the
required electromagnetic field intensity
once the intensity reaches a critical
level it forms a portal that teleports
the ship to their location following
this bill bids farewell to his
granddaughter and rushes toward the ship
as he nears the ship's field intensity
he is drawn inside within he finds the
stuck Carl hurry man I've already
crapped myself twice and uses his new
found ability to release him a few
moments later Catherine arrives at the
scene with Haggen and holds Richard and
Molly at gunpoint forcing them to stay
put she then discloses her plan to
summon a nuclear jet to obliterate the
entire ship Richard tries to explain
that they'll all die if it's not stopped
here however Catherine doesn't listen
and shoots him instead she then
instructs Haggen to enter the ship and
Kill Bill the man soon finds Bill and
starts beating him up however Carl
arrives at the rescue and together they
overpower Haggen before the ship
teleports back in time Bill sends Carl
out meanwhile Molly tricks Catherine
seizes her firearm and shoots her to
death she then heads toward the ship
where she finally reunites with her
boyfriend realizing that the field
intensity is increasing rapidly the
couple hastily exits the research lab
and takes cover somewhere safe
eventually the field intensity becomes
so powerful that it creates a massive
vortex in the sky pulling the USS
Eldridge as well as Catherine's nuclear
jet into it with this the vortex
disappears bringing the situation back
to normal in the final scene we see
Molly visiting her grandfather who has
grown old now this means Bill
successfully traveled back in time and
has since been living with his family
unless the nuclear jet blew up
everything subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank thank you for watching